one of our classic problems to analyze
using Newton's second law is the motion
of two blocks with a rope that's wrapped
around a pulley so imagine we have a
pulley peak and we hang from that block
one and we hang from that block to the
pulley is suspended by another rope and
it's attached to a wall and let's now
try to use Newton's second law to
analyze this motion now going back to
our methodology the first thing we want
to ask ourselves is to identify what are
all the moving pieces so I'm gonna make
my first assumption here that the Rope
pulley surface so that's right here is
frictionless now what that assumption
means is that the pulley will remain at
rest and therefore when we want to break
this problem down our first question our
first question is is to identify all the
moving objects and so we really have
three we have mass which we labeled by
one two and the rope so our goal now is
to identify all the moving objects and
to draw Freebody force diagrams
for each moving object now one of the
things that I'm especially interested in
talking about is to keep in mind to
identify action-reaction pairs so as I
go through and draw these Freebody
diagrams we want to ask ourselves what
forces form Newton's third law
action-reaction pairs so what I'll do is
I'll start with object one
now object one has a gravitational force
m1 G and the Rope is pulling object one
up with the tension at the end of the
rope T rope one so the action reaction
pair to m1 G is the earth is the force
of this mass on the earth which we're
not considering what about the rope
so now let's draw a picture of our rope
and mass this object here is pulling the
rope down and so we have on the rope
object one pulling it down and this is
our action reaction pair what are the
other forces on the rope well over here
object to t2 is pulling the rope down
with the tension at the end of that rope
now also the pulley is exerting a force
on the rope upwards because we have that
force and so these are the force
diagrams on the rope now what about the
action reaction pair to t2 rope well
let's continue and draw two we have
again gravitational force on to the
earth is the action reaction pair the
force of two on the earth upwards is
equal to m2 G of the earth downwards
we're not drawing the earth in this
picture so we don't show it now here is
the force of the rope on two and there
is our other action reaction pair
so these are the Newton's third law
pairs in this object now now that we
have identified all the forces we want
to apply Newton's third law second law
to each of these objects so that are
moving so let's begin by remembering
that if our rope our next assumption
here it's assumed that the mass of the
Rope is very light and then the tension
in the rope is constant and the
implication of that is T to R equals t1
R and that's why we can now identify
this as T and that as T a little bit
later on when we talk about pulleys that
have mass with friction between them the
tension on the two sides of the pulley
will not be the same but for the moment
we've made these assumptions and that
holds and now we just really have
objects one and object two to analyze
and so one of the things that helps a
lot is we need to choose unit vectors in
order to write down the vector equations
for Newton's second law so let's just
here assume for ourselves that M 1 is
greater than m 2 this gives us some
feeling for how the system moves I like
to do this because it gives me a way to
choose my unit vectors to make all the
acceleration is positive so I when M 1
is bigger than M 2 I expect and one to
go down and two to go up and that's how
I'm gonna choose unit vectors J hat 1
now here is the very interesting thing
we choose a separate coordinate system
for each object so I'm gonna write that
down
we want to choose separate unit vectors
for each object and our accelerations
will be with respect to those unit
vectors this is where a lot of people
get tripped up so here I'm choosing J
hat too and when I choose that I expect
a 2 to be positive because 2 is going up
in the direction of J hat and here I
expect a 1 to be positive
also because 1 is going down now I can
draw Newton's second law on 1 so I have
F 1 equals m1 a1 and now I analyze my
forces m1 G is in the positive J hat
direction T is in the negative J hat
direction so I have m1 G minus T equals
m1 a1 which I'm expecting to be positive
and in the same way on to f2 equals m2
a2 I look at my force diagram now notice
J hat is up so T is positive m2 G is -
my direction m2 G equals m2 a2 so I now
have two equations but when I look at
these equations I see that I have three
unknowns I have T a1 and a2 but I have a
constraint because these objects are
moving together and the way I've chosen
the coordinate systems a 1 is equal to
plus a 2 both are positive
with respect to my choice of coordinate
systems and so these two A's are the
same and now I can solve my equations
for T and a and let's quickly do that m1
G minus T equals m1 a and over here
let's solve for the tension for the
accelerations here T is equal to m2 a
plus
m2g and when I substitute the tea into
that equation we'll find some space for
that will write that as if I put in the
m2 minus m2 a minus m2 G and bring the
m2 a to the other side then it's a
little bit of algebra but I think you'll
trust me that this is m1 minus m2 G over
m1 plus m2 now we're almost done we need
to check our answers first off does it
have the dimensions of acceleration
answer yes mass divided by mass G has
the dimensions of acceleration so I
that's my first check always with my
algebra second check what if m1 is equal
to m2 then the acceleration is zero I
expect them to be balanced I've said
that M 1 is greater than m2 positive
sign my a is positive that's how I set
up my coordinate system so I expect that
to by the way our symbol a was equal to
those and so I'm pretty confident that
my result is correct and that's how we
apply Newton's second law to the pulley
with some several assumptions
frictionless surface massless rope and
think about how we chose our unit
vectors each object gets its separate
coordinate system I'm not using the same
coordinate system for each object I
could have but then there would be a
subtlety to this condition the
accelerations would be opposite in sign